you
I've already been introduced you know
about me you know that I'm an alumni two
children went here but there's a much
closer tie to hillsdale college than
just being alumni of Hillsdale and I
want to tell you a little story in the
next few minutes Larry mentioned if you
read the luncheon that there's a
monument over in front of central hall
just a few hundred yards from here and
it's for those hillsdale college
students which fought and what we now
call the Civil War or as my
mother-in-law's family calls it the war
of Yankee aggression but those hillsdale
college students paid the ultimate
sacrifice and if you haven't seen that
Monument I would encourage you to do
that because it's quite moving but they
paid their young lives for ideals and
morals that we still glorify here today
at the college and that is what this
school still stands for but I want to
tell you that at the time that those
young Patriots were giving their lives
there was a man who also fought for the
Union Army and he was engaged in that
conflict from Anderson Indiana his name
was Gideon Daniel Cyril now he was
wounded in battle but he was unimpressed
with the drugs that they used to treat
his wounds so he figured there might be
a business opportunity there so he
started to research those drugs used for
treating infection which led him
eventually to start a pharmaceutical
company and he named a GD searle &
Company now the company grew into a
modest-sized chicago-based
pharmaceutical company that by the 1930s
was producing over a thousand individual
products but it was still a small
struggling company as the country went
into the Great Depression now mr.
Searles brand son by the name of John
Searle had graduated from the University
of Michigan School of Pharmacy we like
to joke around here
that's that school up the street there
and in 1936 mr. John Searle succeeded
his father dr. Howard Claude Cyril as
president of the company and he started
that company on a brand new course one
of his key decisions that he made after
becoming president 1936 of this small
struggling Midwest pharmaceutical
company that his grandfather GD had
started was to concentrate on medicines
that would represent therapeutic
breakthroughs now you remember at the
time the company was producing over a
thousand different products will he
greatly cut that down to narrow in on
just 30 products he focus on and
expanded research which finally
culminated in the introduction of
products that were original and that
made great contributions to the field of
medicine these new products eventually
helped the company become a major player
in the world wide pharmaceutical
industry among the better known of these
project products was a minnow fillin for
asthma Dramamine for motion sickness
probe an teen for peptic ulcers
Metamucil for constipation and
diverticulitis aldactone for
hypertension and edema lomotil for
diarrhea and in Ovid like it or not the
world's first birth control pill and
finally a spurt am known as nutrasweet
or by its market name of equal now mr.
Cyril built not only an excellent
organization but he selected and
developed outstanding men and women you
start to see the tie here between
Hillsdale mr. Cyril always believed in
the human capacity to accomplish great
things which is by the way why he hated
the progressive movement and the new
dealers because he believed their
philosophy and way of thinking stifled
creativity and the work ethic plus he
thought they were just a bunch of
thieves anyway and that they took
hard-working people's money
he was never content to merely keep pace
with the status quo but was determined
to maintain a leadership role for his
company he made the company's motto
research in the service of mankind and
that exemplified his goal in life now
his granddaughter my wife Louise and I
and the Searle family partnered with
this College because we see the same
commitment the same standards and
philosophy at this institution as the
surra family has sought to file for so
many years Hillsdale College has built
not only an excellent organization but
has selected some of the finest staff
and the finest faculty that can be found
we have gathered some of the finest
free-thinking young men and women to be
educated here several of them are here
in the audience today and I have the
pleasure of knowing some of them dr.
Arnn along with the trustees of this
school believe our country is in grave
danger at this moment in history as we
said earlier today we may even be on the
edge of despotism yet we are not
discouraged and we are standing up and
fighting because we believe that though
we are small in size these young people
that come here to learn some of whom
will graduate tomorrow will leave here
with the capacity and desire to
accomplish great things lord knows our
country and world needs them at this
very time we are not content to keep
pace with the standards of our nation
education system but we are also leaders
this school is doggedly persistent in
its goals and objectives just as the
sural company was that is why we invest
these material gains from the past into
this remarkably fiercely independent and
effective college we believe Hillsdale
College will impact our country and our
world in ways we have yet to see now
this building which is going to take
place behind us will have an entranceway
in a gathering place for hopefully what
will
be the very unique bright and persistent
hard working people to come together to
learn to listen to discuss to strategize
to create ideas and hopefully have a
huge significance and will even be
breaking bread together there and that
these same people will leave here with
ideas and motivations that may just
impact and transform our culture in our
world I invite you to please come back
and be part of that group finally I'd
like to thank the Lord God from whom all
gifts flow and I want to thank the
College for all it's meant to me in my
life I'm going to thank my fellow
trustees led by our chairman Bill
Broderick who loved this place and with
whom it is an honor to serve with I want
to thank also particularly John cervini
for starting this ball rolling and for
dr. Larry yarn for his great vision that
he's had for all this and I finally want
to thank the Searle family most
importantly my wife Louise for whom
without this gift you wouldn't be
possible thank you very much for this
opportunity of partnership and for being
here today